Mario Vargas llosa logró hoy un anhelo
de juventud ser o sentirse escritor
francés tras entrar a la academia
francesa en su instalación como inmortal
estuvo rodeado de su familia pero
también de varios amigos entre ellos el
rey emérito Juan Carlos de España para
que yo se pronunció una discurso en
completa o francés durante cerca de una
hora en el que alabó a la literatura
francesa en especial a quien hizo de él
el escritor en el que logró convertirse
también hizo un elogio a su predecesor
en ese sillón a 18 el filósofo Michelle
un sillón que a partir de ahora y hasta
el día de su muerte ocupará el escritor
hispano peruano en su discurso habló
mucho de libertad de derechos humanos de
la incertidumbre de este mundo e hizo
muy pocas referencias a América Latina
En todo caso este discurso luego fue
respondido por uno de los miembros de la
academia francesa que dijo que la obra
de Vargas llosa era simplemente un canto
a la literatura de esta manera también a
callar un poco todas esas voces que se
han opuesto a la entrada de Vargas llosa
a la academia francesa que además hoy ha
hecho historia por convertirse en el
primer escritor que logra ser por parte
de esta prestigiosa institución sin
haber escrito ni una sola hora en
francés